we want to bring you this next video in
the past few minutes boris johnson has
been speaking now this is the first time
that we've heard from the prime minister
since his resignation speech on thursday
let's have a listen
today so today we're we're trying to get
over the the point that the long-term
future uh for this country is in science
and technology that is what is going to
drive jobs and growth for decades to
come so the government's putting 40
billion pounds into
r d scientific r d over the next three
years biggest ever uh investment and
we're putting a billion pounds here in
the incredible crick institute in in
london but i want to stress the
investments going all around the the
country but what we want to see
is uh is uk companies uh more than
matching that and at the moment uh we we
underperformed we have the best
scientists we have the best universities
we have more breakthroughs we have more
fantastic scientific
papers
peer-reviewed papers but unfortunately
we don't often get the commercial
progress that we would like by those
companies so what we want to see is
companies
putting more of their own
cash
into r d so
we're doing a huge amount government's
doing a huge amount but for the uk to
lengthen its lead as a science
superpower we need the companies
okay i'm i'm prime minister this is the
first time uh we've seen you since you
agreed to stand down last week you went
from chocom g7 nato to this dragging out
being dragged out of number 10 in the
most dramatic of fashions uh i'm i'm a
bit shell-shocked by all of it how are
you feeling now i'm i'm determined to
just get over the number one message
today which is about investment in
science in technology and um you know
when i when i look at what we've done
over the last few years with uh with the
investment in in r d creating the uh the
the darpa the new uh the new independent
uh science and innovation agency
i think that the uk is is going to be
set fair but what i want to get over is
that
we can put the taxpayers money in we can
support our incredible scientists our
incredible researchers in the way that
we are and it's happening around there
not just in the the golden triangle of
oxford cambridge london it's happening
around the country but the companies
have to step up to the plate and invest
in investment if you look at france you
look at germany look at america
we have the scientists we have the
breakthroughs but the companies aren't
uk companies
don't invest enough in r d pm i'm i'm
sure viewers will be watching this as
you said yourself there are 40 million
of them that voted for you in in 2019
your sister rachel said on the radio
last night that this was a huge loss for
you she said i know it's a huge loss for
him a huge loss that's almost like a
bereavement
well i i did great say that well
my sisters a wonderful uh a wonderful
journalist i think that uh what i should
really
concentrate on now you're right you know
i'm
doing the last uh few days weeks or
however long it is but the job of
government has got to be carried on in
that period i've i've set out for people
uh what the the tory uh the
parliamentary party
uh have decided that has the inevitable
consequences that it has but my job uh
just in the next
few days and weeks is to uh to continue
with the program on which we were
elected
which included making sure that the uk
was restored to its status as a science
superpower the the country that split
the atom invented the
mri you name it it all happened here but
we don't make enough money out of it
what i want to see is these types of
breakthroughs happening not just in uh
london oxford uh cambridge but that's
fantastic and they must but around the
country that is starting to happen
couple more things in your statement
just talking about the party made their
decision you you talked about the herd
in westminster you said when it moves it
moves and it suddenly stampeded on you
last week do you feel betrayed look i i
don't want to say
any more about all that there's a
there's a contest underway and that must
happen and you know i would wish
wouldn't want to damage anybody's
chances by offering my support i just
have to not to get along
i have to get on and in the last few
days and weeks the the job of the
constitutional function of the prime
minister in this in this situation
is is to discharge
the mandate to continue to discharge the
mandate uh and that's what i'm doing and
i think and the reason we're here today
is because i think
in my i think science technology our
natural genius in this area is one of
the many many things that is going to
carry us forward and make sure that our
our future is very bright let me end
like this then you must be sorry that it
won't be you continuing on
the job i know that whatever happens uh
and you know whoever takes over there is
a there is a great great agenda to be
continued and
that we've put in some pretty fantastic
investments
not just in in science but in
infrastructure in skills uh and in
technology that i think are gonna
enable us us conservatives i should
i should say to keep on with our program
of leveling up and delivering for and
all the people
i'm being tapped on the shoulder so
final question because people will be
cross with me if i don't ask yes just to
be clear you are not uh putting your hat
uh or putting your horse behind any of
the runners and riders i i i it would be
that's not the job of the prime minister
at this stage job friend is at the stage
uh is to let the party uh decide let
them let them get on with it and to
continue uh delivering on the
the projects that we uh were elected to
deliver and you know and what i will say
is is that whoever is is uh is picked i
have no doubt will want to continue to
support brilliant places like the crick
i ca i'm proud to say i was i helped lay
a foundation stone when i was mayor of
london uh here and uh i gave this place
planning permission and i remember the
arguments we had about trying to make
sure that uh the the tube trains didn't
run underneath it and and disturb the
the delicacy of the
of the experiments i can't tell you how
proud it makes me to stand here today
and see it up and running see people
doing incredible things and the point i
want to make to it to everybody is that
there are many many ways in which the uk
is world beating but science technology
r d are amongst them and i want
massive government investment to be
matched by equal enthusiasm from the
from the private sector we tend to make
our money as companies by buying and
selling companies in other countries
they invest more in in the long term and
in in r d that's that's my sermon for
today
you're gonna go down as one of the
shortest serving prime ministers in
history despite winning an 80-seat
majority in 2019 but despite it all
you're putting on a brave face well i'm
i
i'm determined to
get on and deliver
the mandate that that was uh that was
given to us but my job is really just to
uh oversee the the process for the next
few weeks and i'm sure that the outcome
will be good
uh and we just we just need to uh to get
on and as i said i think before to you
the more we focus on uh the people on on
on the people who elect us on their jobs
their hopes uh what they can get out of
uh investment in in science and
technology the more we talk about uh the
the future that we're trying to build
the less we talk about politics uh
westminster the generally happier we
will all be
okay thank you very much